we've been hoping suggesting letting you
know that the DEA this summer was going
to decide whether marijuana would be
kept as a Schedule one drug or
rescheduled and this is really important
because schedule one drugs by their very
classification are much more difficult
to research for medical uses they're
generally criminai zin a much more
aggressive way and the definition of
schedule one drugs is that there is no
currently accepted medical use and a
high potential for abuse
the DEA thought about it as we said they
were and they decided to keep marijuana
as a schedule 1 drug based on quote
scientific and medical evaluation that
they did in partnership with the Food
and Drug Administration here is a quote
from the DEA about this decision saying
the DEA and the FDA continue to believe
that scientifically valid and well
controlled clinical trials conducted
under investigational new drug
applications are the most appropriate
way to conduct research on the medicinal
uses of marijuana yeah it's the most
appropriate way Louis if you're trying
to keep that research very limited very
difficult very expensive and progressing
incredibly slowly yes this this really
has nothing to do with the research
maybe a little bit to do with the
research because as it relates to
funding but to me this is all about just
maintaining the structure and size of
the DEA because let's face it most of
what they do revolves around pot does it
not there's a lot of self-interest
because marijuana enforcement brings in
a ton of money not just for the DEA but
for a ton of agencies and local police
agencies in many cases as well let me
show you the list of schedule 1 drugs
that are on that same list as marijuana
and again schedule 1 drugs defined as
drugs with no currently accepted medical
use in a high potential for abuse so the
list includes heroin LSD marijuana
ecstasy peyote and quaaludes this
reminds me of that little kid game Louis
which
is not like the others and you might be
interested to know that the painkiller
vicodin as well as meth and oxycodone
are scheduled to drugs this is not a
scheduling of marijuana that makes much
sense is it on a side note we also know
that ecstasy actually does have medical
uses yeah right good point apart from
that this is yes this is all about this
is just the the higher-ups at the DEA
and other federal agencies being greedy
yeah it's about money it's about keeping
people's jobs it's about maintaining the
status quo which is good to them with no
concern for the citizens of this country
and it's also demonstrably false that
there's no medical use right we know of
cannabis oil extract being very helpful
in controlling the symptoms of epilepsy
and seizures we know that it's been
useful in treating nausea as a side
effect for a variety of medications
including chemotherapy and there's this
sort of catch-22 where in order to do
more research scientists need to do more
studies in order to do that the studies
have to be approved by federal agencies
including the DEA and the FDA and
occasionally the National Institute on
Drug Abuse but it's much more difficult
to get those approvals while it is
schedule one where are you on this issue
Jason I know it seemed earlier like you
have very strong feelings about this
research issue
well actually did some interviews that's
of some researchers at UCSF one point
and you know they're actually you know
not about marijuana but about LSD and
they're actually using it for
Alzheimer's patients right help them
kind of cope with their end of death
syndrome as well as I know there's uses
for certain native tribes with the use
peyote to kind of you know to solve kind
of the same thing major anxiety issues
and yeah you know there's there are
definite uses for you know not only
marijuana but LSD peyote to you know
just solve major issues with the brain
there's no logically consistent case to
me and I think Jason is is getting at
this correctly for legal cigarettes
legal alcohol and not marijuana period
whatever your personal feelings are
about smoking weed right and as you know
Lewis I believe that the actual
smoking process of anything is
demonstrably bad for your lungs that's a
separate issue like my personal views
about smoking stuff are completely
different from the empirical sort of
bankruptcy of saying Oh cigarettes
should be legal and alcohol should be
legal but it should be difficult to even
study medicinal uses of marijuana well
and you don't need to smoke it but let's
add another huge one opiates are legal
too and these harmful incredibly
addictive painkillers are is that's what
we give to people who are suffering from
pain when they could be using marijuana
products which is it's far safer and far
less addictive arguably not addictive at
all instead we're loading them up on on
percocets and vicodins and oxys and not
to mention when you look at the schedule
to nature of a lot of those opiate
painkillers that lewis mentions in the
northeast where there's a real problem
with the heroin epidemic if you look at
how many heroin addicts started with a
legitimate prescription for opiate
painkillers because of an injury they
had or for whatever reason it's huge so
those schedule 2 drugs that are
apparently not as as concerning as
marijuana based on the scheduling are in
many cases actually a gateway to heroin
use and we still have really no strong
evidence that opening up cannabis for
medical research will actually serve as
a gateway to other drug use the entire
system is bankrupt lewis this decision
by the fda we had sort of our hopes up
that there would be a rescheduling but
ultimately the status quo prevailed yeah
like it tends to do the DEA just
completely morally bankrupt at this
point hey make sure to check out our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our e d
di t you can suggest stories there and
so much more